mentioned a little bit earlier about the
anniversary of the death of Ashley
Babbitt
and how the comparison here really shows
you the two-tiered system of justice
well it it goes right to the heart of
the Ashley Babbitt story Ashley
Babbitt's mother was just arrested
Ashley Babbitt's mother
was in Washington DC for the anniversary
of her daughter's death at the hands of
a trigger-happy Capitol Hill cop and
Ashley Babbitt's mother wanted to lay
down some flowers for her daughter
and she was arrested
it was our plan to go lay steps flowers
on the steps of the capitol for the four
people unarmed American citizens that
lost their lives that day that would be
my daughter Ashley Babbitt Roseanne
Boylan who was beaten by a metropolitan
police officer Lena Morris Kevin Grayson
and Benjamin Phillips all lost their
lives that day as unarmed American
Patriots so we wanted to lay flowers on
the steps of the Capitol they were
letting people in they had it all
barricaded off they were letting people
in but they would not let us in with our
signs and and uh and our flags and and
so we opted to walk down the street that
was already closed off so we laid
flowers on the east side I'm not sure
which side was and then when we went to
go turn the corner there was no sidewalk
for us to walk on there were other
citizens walking on that sidewalk we
were not allowed to because we had
American flags at the United States
capital so um we we walked down the road
as because we had no sidewalk to walk on
and our option was to cross four lanes
of traffic and walk on the other side
where I also would not have been able to
honor my Daughter by laying a rose for
her around the Capitol building and so
we walked on the road and I was arrested
aggressively by one uh that man right
there yeah the one right there the um
tall bald man
what was this woman arrested for
jaywalking basically for jaywalking I
think the actual charge was that she was
arrested for blocking and obstructing
roadways because she walked into some
areas where they had some impediments
set up and she wasn't supposed to be
walking there
blocking and obstructing roadways
black lives matter
shut down highways in LA
Seattle
Massachusetts Washington DC all over the
country I was in multiple places
during the BLM Madness
as the BLM movement shut down those
freeways and highways for hours in some
cases totally blocking traffic nobody
did anything about it and this woman
grieving the killing of her daughter
wants to lay a rose at the people's
house
at the Capitol
and she's not allowed to she gets
arrested for doing that
she says that the cops they knew this
was a bad bad group of people why
because they were waving American flags
had the group been waving Pride Flags
BLM Flags
any of those other Anarchist flags
sheikhavara flags you know the cops
would not have done a damn thing to
obstruct them
because those people they would have
been left Wingers
they would have been on the same side as
our current regime
but because Ashley Babbitt's mother and
the protesters were waving an American
flag the cops saw that they said oh this
is a threat
can you imagine how
far has our country Fallen
that these cops they see an American
flag they say that's that's a symbol of
a threat
we've got to go arrest this woman
she shouldn't be she shouldn't be laying
down a rose for her daughter at the
Capitol
our regime affords greater protection to
people who burn the American flag than
it does to people who wave the American
flag
that's not hyperbole
we all know that that is the case if you
if you burn the American flag well
you're probably just an aggrieved victim
of this terrible awful Society this
traditional American country that we're
doing our best to get rid of as quickly
as possible
but if you wave the American flag
why you're probably one of those
far-right extremists we live under a
regime today when I say regime it's it's
unusual language because we usually only
refer to political systems in other
places as regimes we never refer to our
own country as a regime it's only
there's other places where they have
governments that we don't like that's
always the regime but a regime just
means a political order
and so our political order obviously has
transformed pretty significantly over
the last 50 60 years certainly over the
last 200 years
we are not living in the political order
of the founding fathers and the framers
our system of government does not work
like the bill up on Capitol Hill and
Schoolhouse Rock right we live in a very
different one
and and we live in one today where
the Department of Justice refers to
parents who don't want their kids to
have their genitals chopped off and have
their kids be told that they're evil
because they're white refers to those
parents as domestic terrorists
that's the system that we're living in
we're living under a regime where we are
told that people who burn down
courthouses were people who murder
dozens of people over the course of
months where people who threatened to
assassinate top conservative public
officials they're all referred to as
mostly peaceful protesters but the guy
in the horn hat and the smiley Florida
guy who took a picture posing with Nancy
Pelosi's lectern those are
insurrectionist terrorists the greatest
threat to our country that's the regime
we're living in okay and I'm not whining
about it I'm not screaming and crying
I'm just telling you that's how it is
and so when these Court decisions come
down
and
if you throw a can at Ted Cruz's head
basically the liberal establishment just
laughs It Off
where a mother grieving the loss of her
daughter wants to lay a rose at the
Capitol and the cops arrest her for it
no you're one of the bad ones you're one
of those conservative ones we're going
to throw you in the in the squad car why
I don't know we don't like the cut of
your jib you looked at us funny you get
in the car just don't be surprised
that's the way that it is
and it ties right back to the top of
what we're talking about when a handful
of conservatives
those intransigent conservatives
say hey we need a little bit more change
in Washington DC than just getting
another tax cut Bill through
when a group of conservatives say we
need
structural serious change to the way
power is wielded in this country and the
way that we view good and bad and true
and false and the things that we exalt
and the things that we discourage we
need to kind of change that because it's
gotten a little bit of skew I don't
think that those conservatives are the
bad guys
I think they are doing
the most that they can do and the Very
bare minimum of what needs to be done
and I don't think that anyone should
should attack them for it because it
took us three more days to to get Kevin
McCarthy into the speaker Suite which he
already moved into in the first place by
the way he already moved in there before
he even won the vote okay the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles
kwels at checkout for two months free
on all of the annual plans we will see
you at the member block
[Music]
foreign